And this is where I disagree with Hijab.
Let's watch it for ourselves and I'm
going to be giving my criticism and I'm
going to be giving Avery credit where it
is due. And any Muslim that disagrees
with this, you have issues within
yourself. I didn't realize this
actually. Please keep talking. Keep
talking. Thank you. This is good. So,
what you're going to have to do Thank
you. So, this is what you're going to
have to deal with.
Just imagine the people back in the day
when they would have to travel certain
distances for months or even years. What
is one thing that they would carry with
them?
The Quran. Why? Because they did not
have it on their mobile devices or their
gadgets. Brothers and sisters, imagine
you have a app, the Qurani app, which
not only shows you how much rewards you
get, but reminds you to read the Quran.
Gives you reminders. Download the Qurani
app now and let it testify for you on
Yom al-Qiyamah that you read it wherever
you was. So, Muhammad Hijab had a debate
with Avery yesterday and Muhammad Hijab,
you are my brother in Islam and I love
you for the sake of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
But, I have to be honest here, guys.
Absolutely honest. I know there's going
to be some biases, etc., but we have to
be honest and we have to give credit to
Avery where credit is due. For you, some
of you guys, this might come as a shock.
Like, "Ali, what are you talking about?"
Well, guys, Allah says to us in the
Quran, "Be firm and upholders of justice
even if it is against yourself." Let's
watch it for ourselves and I'm going to
be giving my criticism and I'm going to
be giving Avery credit where it is due.
And any Muslim that disagrees with this,
you have issues within yourself.
Inshallah. Let's watch the video.
Inshallah. The
Quran clearly is responding to a
biblical narrative. It's clearly
responding to a Christian narrative.
It's saying they did not kill him. They
did not crucify him. What What I can
show be a lamb. It was made to appear
as if they did. So, the question is
this.
So, that is correct. Yep, that is
correct. Hijab is right that the Quran
is acknowledging by saying that they did
not kill him nor did they crucify him,
which in return, logically and
rationally, follows that
the Quran is aware, whoever the author
is, Allah or the Prophet Muhammad, peace
be upon him, that the Christians say A.
The Quran is saying, "No." This It's not
saying that. It
is rejecting that and saying, "No, this
is what actually happened."
Let's carry on. Is the Quran with this
verse
aware of what
is being said by Christians? Is this
correct that they say that he was killed
and crucified? Is that correct
representation? And is it then
correcting that or not? Yes or no? Okay,
I believe that is a valid question from
Hijab in this specific segment. It's a
valid question. Is it yes or no? So,
let's see [clears throat] what Avery had
to say. And let's be just Muslims. We
have to be fair and we have to be just.
Beautiful. So, now I get to fully
answer. So, this is what you're This is
notice the difference. The answer is
yes. Here's a quick answer to yes. Yes,
it is correcting what people say. Yeah,
now we're talking.
Okay, I believe that is a valid question
from Hijab in this specific segment.
It's a valid question. Is it yes or no?
So, let's see what Avery had to say. And
let's be just Muslims. We have to be
just. Beautiful. So, now I get to fully
answer. So, this is what you're This is
notice the difference.
The answer is yes. Here's a quick answer
to yes. Yes,
it is correcting what people say. Yeah,
now we're talking. Good. Now, what Avery
said there,
I'll be honest with you. That's why you
saw the whole demeanor of Muhammad Hijab
completely
change. And Avery's demeanor, which
we're going to observe very closely,
shifted cuz he just realized the biggest
mistake he made in his life. And that's
why I say this to Avery. And I'm going
to come to my criticism as well.
The other stuff as well.
Is that Avery, look, me and you, I think
we're on the same grounding. Like, you
have no Like, degrees, etc. I'm not
Look, me and you are on the same
footing. Yes? Okay.
I'm going to come to your psychology of
why you're doing this. Because I'll be
honest with you, have you seen me behave
like you? I know my place, bro. I don't
speak to certain Christians who are very
well versed, etc. Cuz you know why? I
don't want to make Islam look bad by
acting It's not about me. It's about
Islam.
I'm going to come to my criticism of
your psychology and why you're doing
this in a minute. That's a bit later.
But, you just admitted, Avery,
that it is correcting.
Did you just understand what you've
done, Avery? To not only yourself, to
Christianity and this Islamic dilemma
argument. You shot yourself in the foot.
And I'll be honest with you, I'll be
using this till the day I die. That you
admitted on camera to Hijab that
there's a correction. The moment you
said that, your whole argument of the
Islamic dilemma is in the bin.
Without being biased, it's It is in the
bin. It's rubbish. Let's carry on. It's
correcting what they say, not what the
scriptures say. But, the Christians and
the Jews. So, notice how Notice how Let
me Let me land. I'll let you speak
uninterrupted, right? So, thank you. I
appreciate it. So, notice the
difference. At first, you were arguing
that Muhammad is aware of what the
scripture says and is correcting the
scripture, not just what the Jews and
Christians say. But, you just changed
your question to, "Is Muhammad aware of
what the Christians say and is therefore
correcting what the Christians say?" And
the answer to that is yes. Unbeknownst
to him that what they are saying is
actually in the Injil, in the Gospel.
So, Muhammad is going against the
Christians, unknowingly going against
the Gospel. And here's the point.
Hold on. Let me land.
Now, I'm going to land. Keep talking
actually.
Thank you. I appreciate it. I didn't
realize this, BUT IT'S PROBABLY
>> [laughter]
>> I DIDN'T REALIZE THIS ACTUALLY. Please
keep talking. This thing It doesn't like
It doesn't help you, Avery. You know,
when you do this stuff like this and the
whole question stuff, it genuinely
doesn't help you. You know, this whole
showman thing, etc. That's why when you
came to me at my table, I could match
your energy, bro, with showmanship, you
know. There, etc. We had a fun time. You
promoted the mad, etc. It It doesn't
work. That argument you made, you've
realized the pit you fell into. You've
realized what you've done there and
that's not going to help you. And we can
see from your body language, you know.
And that's why you see Hijab was
more relaxed cuz this argument was a
knockout. But, let's carry on.
Thank you. This is good. So, what you're
going to have to do Thank you. So, this
is what you're going to have to deal
with. What you're going to have to deal
with is Muhammad commanding you not to
just not to believe what we say or
disbelieve what we say. Notice he never
And this is where I disagree with Hijab.
Like, bro, when your enemy is making a
mistake, stop interrupting him. Look,
Avery At the moment Hijab said, "I just
need to let you talk." Yes, Hijab. Don't
make any remarks. You should have just
been dead silent there. Because what he
done to himself, this is why criticism
The only criticism of Hijab is here is
this.
Bro, shh. He just He just knocked
himself out. Let him. When your enemy is
making a mistake, don't disturb him.
goes against the scripture. Show me
anywhere anywhere where Muhammad says,
"Don't believe in what the scripture
says." Show me one time where Muhammad
said that. Okay, Avery, let's go back to
the point. This is the point. Please
answer. There you go. Look, Hijab done
with it. And I just want to just mention
just one small point that is to be
mentioned. Okay.
If the author of the Quran is the
Prophet Muhammad, the fact that that
verse says they did not kill him nor did
they crucify him,
is evident. He doesn't need to He
doesn't need to come out and say And
which he has. There's verses where he's
told the companions, "Why are you
reading the old scriptures when we have
the Quran?"
It's done. But, if the author of the
Quran is the Prophet Muhammad, which
they claim, the Prophet Muhammad said
they did not kill him nor did they
crucify him.
Hello. Hello. No, no, hold on. This is
what you said. You said that it was a
correction. Okay. It was a correction.
>> you guys to please I'm so sorry for just
interrupting. But, please look
carefully. I'm going to zoom into
Avery's body language. This is exactly
what happens when every time he gets
caught out. His nervous laugh, etc. When
he came to my table, okay?
Watch his body language very carefully
cuz he knows what he done to himself.
And you You admitted You actually I'm
surprised and I have to I have to
commend you, actually. Yeah. I thought
you'd be a belligerent young man.
Okay, I thought, you know, you put on
the hat. You put on the
But, I have to say you're better than I
thought you'd be. And I agree with
Hijab. This is where I have to give
credit where it is due.
I admire Avery's honesty. When he said
yes,
he shot himself in the head, but at
least he was honest enough
to say yes. Some integrity was there.
Yeah. And I applaud Avery
for being honest and saying yep, that
was a correction. Your whole Islamic
dilemma is in the bin. Thank you, Avery,
very much. No, no.
You're better than I thought you'd be.
You You do You do You do have a future
in in in in in in in in in in in in in
in in content creation and influencing.
You do have a future in this. And you
You know what? There's some I'm starting
to like him. Yeah. I'm starting to like
him. [laughter] Yeah, he's got some He's
got some good qualities. But, just
That's usually the effect I have on
people. Okay, the only reason I like
that because you look like a buck buck
tooth
buck tooth
That's okay.
>> [laughter]
>> But, that's beside the point now.
We're just having a We're having a We're
having a good time. This is a I'm a
humble chef. I like to cook, giant.
>> Okay, whatever.
Let Let me just say this to you, right?
The point I'm making to you is is is
this. You have just admitted when the
Quran says
that when you see that Look Look Look
Look Look Look Look Look Look Look Look
Look Well, well, when you see that Look
Look Look Look Look carefully, guys.
Look Look Look how Avery does not like
cuz he's like, "Yo,
I I made a big mistake." And he's like,
"Yo, yo, no, no, no, no. I didn't say
that." Look Look Look at his body
language. Look very carefully, guys.
Just please observe him very carefully.
Woah, I didn't say anything. No, no, no,
no. Let me finish what I'm saying. And
is it then correcting that or not? Yes
or no? Beautiful. So, now I get to fully
answer. So, this is what you're This is
notice the difference. The answer is
yes. Here's a quick answer to yes.
But, you just misrepresented me. I never
said about anything
The answer is yes. Here's a quick answer
to yes.
You didn't say anything yet. Yes, you
did. You said that what I admitted that
what the Quran says I never said
anything about what the Quran says. The
answer is yes. Here's a quick answer to
yes.
We're talking about what Muhammad said
in Hadith. Avery, you haven't finished
my sentence. So, you would not You could
You You see that? The fact that Look, he
hasn't Hijab isn't even finished his
sentence and he's already panicking cuz
he knows
him saying the word yes, is it
correcting? Night Night game over. So,
he's like, "Oh, damn. I didn't say
that." Yes, you did. Yes, you did. You
said that it is correcting. They don't
know what I'm saying.
I said when the Quran [laughter] when
the Quran said
Guys, catch that awkward laugh. He has
had that laugh with Libyano. He's had it
with me. He's had it with
Hashim, with Hijab, with that guy who
said if Jesus or no and goes on what
they talk about. He had it everywhere.
Yep, and he knows look you can see his
cheeks are going red. They did not kill
him. They did not crucify him. What was
made to appear to them that that was the
case, yeah? You admitted that that was
what you thought was a correction of
Muhammad of the Christian community. But
you thought he didn't know what's in the
New Testament, okay? You don't know
what's in the New Testament yet it's
still a correction somehow. The point is
is the crucifixion mentioned in the New
Testament? Yes, the crucifixion is
without a doubt mentioned in the New
Testament and it's mentioned multiple
times in multiple reports. It says in
the Quran that it was made to appear to
them that it was the case. It didn't
really happen. This is a correction of
the Quran which shows the author of the
Quran whether you believe it's the
Prophet Muhammad or we believe it's
Allah, the author of the Quran was fully
aware of what was in that book and he
was fully aware what was in circulation
with Christians and Jews and not only
did he reject it, he corrected it.
Anyone that's watching this and is fair
will have to admit that is exactly
what's happening.
And in a nutshell, guys, without
carrying on
I'm going to talk to you about
Avery's psychology in a minute
is that when it comes to Lot sleeping
with his daughters, when it comes to
Solomon doing magic, when it comes to
Jesus did not die, Jesus not being God,
etc. It is throughout the Quran
corrections are happening. Corrections
when the Jews come and say Mary is an
adulterer, Jesus is not a Messiah, the
Quran is coming and correcting them. And
that is what Avery has admitted.
And that is clear. Now the question is
this, guys. The question is the
following. I am
Ali Dawah. I do videos. Have you ever
seen me go on to platforms where PhD and
individual Christian who's had PhD
degree, etc. No, you know why? Because I
know there are people who are doing that
for their job. I wouldn't go and put
myself unless I have some stuff to gain,
popularity, views, money.
Yes, etc.
I would not put myself because I'm doing
a disservice to my reputation if it's
about my reputation. If it's not about
my reputation, I hope it is it's not cuz
I I don't do it for my reputation. If
it's for the my religion and if I really
care about my religion, the last thing
I'll ever do is put myself on platforms
of well-versed Christians. They're on
battle footing anyways. They believe in
the Trinity. Yeah, I could debate the
Trinity with anyone, but I know there
are people who are doing a fantastic
job. That's probably Libyano, Muhammad
Hijab, the rest, okay?
I don't. The only time cuz I put myself
in Avery's shoes. Sometimes I do that.
When I disagree with someone I'm like,
"Yo, let me put myself in the shoes."
Why would I go and make myself look like
an idiot?
Shoot myself in the foot and make my
faith that I believe in look absolutely
stupid, gets used against me.
So many people come to Islam in our
Dawah tables.
It's because of the Trinity not making
sense.
And I had to come to one conclusion,
which is the following.
Avery
like I said, me and you on the same
foot. Yes? I don't have a degree, etc.
I'm a YouTuber, I do discussions,
apologetics, whatever it is for that
matter. We're on the same ground, etc.
Okay? That's why when you came to my
table you found your match. Yes? You
want to do showing, etc. Like you know,
you want to do make it like a little
show, etc. I'm ready for it, bro. Do you
get it? I'll bring the triangles and the
squares. triangles and squares, okay?
And we know what happened there. So the
claim is this.
Why are you doing this?
You know what it shows? It shows you
don't give two flying damns about your
faith or even your reputation.
There is something else going on that is
causing you to go and do this at the at
the at your own destruction. And I
genuinely believe, bro
it might be I might be totally wrong
about this. Just my subjective opinion.
It might be that, bro
you are just doing this
for the money.
And that is connected to your wife slash
girlfriend.
So to me I believe Avery, you have a
deep insecurity and your wife is not at
on your league. I think you think your
wife is a catch. Look, I might be
totally wrong, okay?
And the only thing I can bring this down
to is
you are just trying to, you know, throw
money at her
and keep this relationship going. And I
believe this is going to come out
eventually, I believe. Because there's
nothing I can logically and rationally
bring it down to for you to go and make
a mockery of yourself, your faith your
faith. Yes? And look I can absolute
idiotic Yes? Even like for
example, I'll show you two more clips.
Is Jesus fully God?
We we say that he's truly God.
Is he fully God or not? Already
answered.
>> Yes or no? God we don't say fully God.
Can you be caused and uncaused at the
same time? Depends Yeah, it depends on
what you mean.
In these two clips you saw Hijab asking,
you can't have an uncaused cause.
Is Jesus fully God?
He's refusing It's like someone said to
me, "Is Allah fully God?"
No, we say he's truly Allah. What do you
mean, bro? We never have these problems.
So the question I'm going to ask is
this. If I had this many clips of being
caught out I would leave the Dawah scene
cuz it's an embarrassment not just for
myself, but I'm making my religion look
terrible.
That's why I have to give credit where
it's due, Avery that when you said yes I
couldn't believe you said yes. It's like
when I stopped you and I said
which religion believes
God
a man
does miracles and claims himself to be
God. You said Islam.
Like everyone, even the audience was
laughing at you.
And then I realized to myself, bro
there is a pressure on you to do this
and it is not the pressure of making my
faith or defending my faith.
It is something else and my conclusion
is, bro, I believe your wife is way out
of your league
and you are head over heels with her
and you are just trying to provide a
lifestyle for her to her to stay with
you or something like that. That's
something I I could be completely wrong.
It might come out that might be the
truth, but what I'm saying is, bro, I
don't know whoever whatever
anyone would go to these levels of
humiliating themself on camera and
debating opponents that are far above
their pay grade. And if you come and
debate me, look you're not even Libyano,
bro. Libyano is lethal. That's why when
he comes in you run for your life. I
don't blame you.
Libyano is dangerous, bro. Like if I was
a Christian
I don't want I would stay away from
anything that starts with the word L.
Libyano Hell no.
Anything. Lamb. I'm not eating lamb
anymore, bro. It starts with L. Okay?
Cuz it's going to cook me. I'm going to
be the sacrificed lamb. Libyano is cold
as ice and dangerous and I don't blame
you. So you are going to these people
like Muhammad Dawah, etc. They are not,
bro. Come debate me. Yes? Okay. Even
then I would say, "You know what, guys?
Us in the Dawah table and all of these
Shahadas I'm going to show you
this shows you Islam is the truth. You
know why? Cuz when you speak to people
on a one-to-one level genuinely and tell
them about Islam, they are flocking to
Islam and we have evidence of that. We
have thousands of Christians around the
globe that we provide this guided prayer
mats to and they learn how to pray
salah. Thousands. In our campaign that
we've done for Ramadan, most of them
were ex-Christians.
Nothing else to be said, guys,
inshallah. And Avery, I'll be honest
with you
I don't know, man. I just think if the
issue is the issue of your wife, bro
don't humiliate yourself cuz I'll be
honest with you, there's going to be a
point where your wife is going to see
through. And I'll be honest with you
man, she's going to leave you one way or
another. If If that's your concern, I'm
just I'm just speculating. If that's
your concern, bro, stop making yourself
look stupid, man. You're really Look,
Islam doesn't need Christianity, okay?
We're doing fine as it is. People are
coming to Islam, but don't make a
mockery of yourself, bro. Like from a
YouTuber to a YouTuber, we're on the
foot same footing, etc. As an advice to
you, I'm telling you, bro, you're making
yourself look like an absolute
It's up to you to carry on and I'll be
honest with you, just carry on
embarrassing yourself. That was my
little two cents
on this matter and till next time.
Assalamualaikum warahmatullah
wabarakatuh.